hi reg so do you think as LeBrons
playing the game this weekend versus the
Clippers and the Lakers it's more
importantly last night versus the Lakers
as he's getting his head beat in by
Isiah Thomas and the Lakers he's saying
to himself I could be playing with these
guys
which team is more talented if I take
away LeBron from the Cavs are the Cavs
better than the Lakers LeBron is not on
either team or look around on the Lakers
yeah he's not on either team the Lakers
are better then why not go there because
LeBron it's all about Championships I'm
not quite sure the Lakers can't compete
with Houston Golden State maybe even San
Antonio so you just can't you just can't
go for two the Lakers for the sake of
going he has to be one of the top three
teams and if he goes to the Lakers they
are not a top three team but do you see
I'm trying to figure out if you handicap
this if he goes to Philadelphia let's
say you got Ben Simmons who sort of
plays that same role he's not a shooter
you know he has the ball he's talented
you got mb'd but does philadelphia fit
better I personally I think Cleveland
let me start by saying I don't think
he's going to leave Cleveland okay
that's my personal opinion he is not
going to leave Cleveland but if he was
to leave two places come to mind number
one I think Philadelphia to be perfect
because you stay in the East and you
only have to face Houston and/or Golden
State in the NBA Finals and it's an
easier route to get to the NBA Finals if
you stay east the second place would be
Houston which I don't see because they
already have two ball dominant guys and
the pecking order and the way they've
been playing all year really has been
said and if you add LeBron to that mid
mix which would be great don't get me
wrong they I'm sure Mike D'Antoni could
make it work I just don't think they
have room for three-ball dominant guys
and then the Lakers you don't you see
them forth on it yeah I don't I just
don't see the Lakers as well as they've
played as of the all-star break and as
young and talented and having Magic
Johnson have to hell I just don't see
them having a shot of getting on the
Bron when they put up billboards he
could get billboards put up right never
win see Webb they did that in Sacramento
like this I think the Maloof brothers
said we're gonna mow your grass Chris
don't leave so he he said he didn't
leave and then they ended up trading him
crazy do great you didn't get any
billboards in Indiana did you of course
not what you weren't leaving not by my
own I thought that you were gonna end up
with the Knicks though they fell down in
Houston there's no way I could have ever
played for New York I just in my bones
there's no way I would rather cut off my
right wrist and play for the New York
Knicks were you better than L in Houston
at that time you see know what at that
time
well he was younger um he was a few
years younger and they wanted to go with
the new flashy car that's the old Buick
knowing the whole beautiful hey beauty
khalaby get there for the Buick would
get there they wanted to get there in a
hurry and you saw how that ended up it's
a foregone conclusion that James
Harden's winning the MVP right okay
hands down has he done more for his team
than Anthony Davis says I look at body
of work more consistent Anthony Davis
has been fantastic as of late but
Anthony Davis has also been hurt off and
on and early part of the year you could
make a case before the injury to boogie
cutter he was the MVP of that team James
Harden on the James Harden on Houston
it's been 100% James Harden okay see I
make a case for Chris Paul boogie
cousins I would say for the first two
and a half months
what's the paint out of MVP clip but man
Anthony Davis there's nobody like
there's nobody like him in the league
he's been great as of late but you can't
make a case for MVP what she has but you
can't win the MVP in a month you got to
put a body of work together who's gonna
finish second Durant
LeBron and oh and or LeBron I would
probably go
I'm gonna go Harden I'm gonna go LeBron
Durant Anthony Davis okay because those
other two Durant and LeBron body of work
and you know what I'm also gonna put
demar derozan in there maybe he may be
he's bit the Marja Rosen has been
balling for Toronto balling and no one
likes to talk about it because they play
up north in a different country but if
you look at what he has done personally
and changing his games and still staying
consistent and then winning and leading
the East demar derozan as well as Dwayne
Casey when in coach of the year they
need to get serious consideration do you
think there's an anti Canada bias I
think so because of what they've done in
the playoffs over the last few years
they've been built for their regular
season it's like Groundhog Day for them
they're gonna win 50-plus games getting
to the playoffs and Kyle Lowry is going
to struggle and they're gonna get
balanced in the first a second round now
they kind of change that last year but
they were headed that way with Milwaukee
went up big on them but they found a way
to win that series and and prevail so we
all want to see what they're gonna do in
the playoffs that's why we're not like
you know everyone's kind of discounting
them because of their their playoff
prowess are you but you're sold on
Toronto you think Toronto is am to be in
the East yes I do yeah I like the bench
it's deep yeah I'm getting a little more
sold on them it's just you know a
history lesson here where you know we
built up Toronto and they look good and
then all of a sudden they get into a
seven-game series and then they get
exposed but but this year is different
well it could be different but I'm going
to tell you what's shaping up here with
the Lakers lost last night they dropped
it for so now
there you have a game ahead of
Washington and anywhere between three
and eight I mean if you go on a two or
three-day a losing streak Indiana which
is currently three could move down to
seven but they're playing well right now
big win on the road in Boston last night
for the Pacers but I think the I think
the Cavs want to settle in at four or
five that way they get Washington in the
first round which they've dominated over
the years during the playoffs second
round they would get Toronto who they've
dominated over the years during the
playoffs I don't think the Cavaliers
want to stay at three because they don't
want any business right now if standings
state as they are today that first-round
matchup would be Benjamin's
Joe LMB in Philadelphia they don't want
to see that they don't want to see them
in the first round I think they would be
more comfortable not to say that they're
going to be losing games on purpose but
I think it's better matchup and Road to
the NBA Finals
if Cleveland stays at four or five I had
an idea came to me late last night as
all my great ideas too and that is how
about all the teams eliminated from the
playoffs every team that doesn't make
the playoffs is in the lottery and
everybody gets one ping-pong ball I like
that
that way we take out tanking you only
get one one ball no matter where you
finish and then you know so we don't
have to worry about any of this where
the Commissioner is calling you saying
hey playa you know put a good product
out there one ball that's it play as
hard as you can and somebody's going to
get rewarded a team that didn't make
plans has an Adam Silver been on this
show before to be proposed well you can
do it
you had why don't you do it on my behalf
reg and then you can take a credit go
ahead well I can't take credit now set
it on there and people steal for me all
the time on the air don't will you worry
about it we're a team man that is true
and we're gonna miss you in Los Angeles
we're coming out and you're going to
Pittsburgh I know going to Pittsburgh
March is the best time of the year
we always talk about this you've got the
NBA starting to shape form and look
towards the playoffs you know you got
spring training
you've got March Madness now you have
Oklahoma and Rhode Island
I own a Duke Liu Brooklyn Radford vs.
Villanova and Alabama Virginia Tech yes
okay so I have Villanova obviously
moving on
I have Alabama beating Virginia Tech mm
oh I love what Virginia Tech and what
they've done there Duke and I owner is
gonna be a good game but I have Duke and
you know people are saying Oklahoma
should not have been in the tournament
looking at their resume two and eight
over their last 10 ballgames they had a
great first half
terrible big 12 but it's so hard to
prepare for these teams come tournament
time because you don't see them a lot
and I think that young man tre young
could put on a show to try to show
everyone why they belong so I think
that's going to be a fantastic matchup
was rhode island who was one of my
sleeper teams all year they play hard at
both into the floor
they are they are good enough to go to
the Final Four believe it or not I know
I watched them yesterday and you know
they ended up losing that game but David
yeah yeah but they they're good enough
to go to the Final Four row down they
really are
Emery great guard play and that's what
you need in this tournament you need to
have obviously upperclassmen leadership
well coached and you need to have great
guard play if you have that combination
and you can you know find a way to
generate often I agree with you we're
Rhode Island is one of those teams it's
gonna be a fantastic matchup with
Oklahoma could you out shoot tre young
right now no I could not give me a month
[Laughter]
I don't even think you're gonna need a
month I don't think we don't I don't
think we I think in two weeks I would
put my money on you against Ray young
put me through the Dan Patrick workout
I'm good to go yes yes I I'm starting
that instructional video I'm gonna do
that what was that baseball remember the
Fred McGriff baseball video yeah Tom Tom
a man ski I'm gonna come out with my
bass
Fred McGriff points to the camera its
instruction video for you all right I
got one for you would you rather be a 19
year old playing professionally overseas
or being the NCAA tournament I would
probably want to be playing in the NCAA
tournament and is that person after this
tournament turning pro yes yes I would
want to be in the tournament okay
all these kids grow up this is what they
know this is what all they've ever known
is wanting to play in this tournament so
I wouldn't absolutely want to play in
the NCAA tournament
yeah but maybe our generation but these
you know these younger kids they're not
as enamored with you know March Madness
doesn't mean as much to them I don't
think you know there are yeah but maybe
to their parents it does maybe to their
pillows yeah maybe there's nothing wrong
with eight again at the end of the day
there's nothing wrong with getting a
paycheck but you're playing in a foreign
country right
yeah why not be in front of family and
friends playing for a beloved you know
college institution and having a shot to
hear one shiny moment I still think
there's got to be some pageantry in it I
know college basketball has taken a lot
of hit over the years and rightfully so
to their own doing but at the end of the
day you can tell me people are not going
to wake up wanting to watch all these
games starting early in the morning on
Thursday morning they should have a song
every Tuesday and when Tuesday and
Wednesday but really Thursday morning
how about a new song one shining
paycheck that'd be kind of nice
[Laughter]
we were talking movies before you came
on we have certain movies that have
holes in them I didn't realize this with
Shawshank Redemption go ahead tell
Reggie the the whole Seaton with
Shawshank Redemption and I didn't even
realize I don't know if this could
affect you when you watch the movie
again
where the the poster the Raquel Welch
poster that's covering the tunnel how
did Andy Dufresne hang it up from inside
the tunnel oh good point he's gonna
picked up a rock or something so and
what people are saying is that it was
actually just hanging from the top and
there was nothing on the bottom but
that's not gonna make me be like oh my
god this is not true two floors I mean
you nitpicking now okay all right here's
one reg home alone
Kevin yeah Kevin doesn't call the cops
he has the ingenuity to be able to fend
off these bad guys and he's in a
high-end neighborhood you know that
they're gonna come to the house right I
mean he's in he's in the suburbs they're
coming out there okay you guys have you
ever heard of escapism sometimes you've
got to go to the movies to kind of
escape things we're really we're realist
okay well that's the case all the
transformer movies really no I haven't
seen one of those transformer movies
okay all right I love you but all the
transformer movies I pull my hair out
okay red Cheers one Karate Kid why is he
penalized for the kick to the face it's
illegal yeah yeah did that just blow
your mind there reg well what was the
other kid penalized for the sweeping to
the knee sweep leg sweep delayed I think
they gave I think they gave him a
penalty yes he was
yeah Daniel song wasn't yeah was not
penalized to the face no I'm never gonna
win ever gonna watch that again what's
your favorite movie of all time let's
try to guess Reggie's favorite movie no
you gotta go back all right we'll say
this in the 80s okay then that's safe to
me okay
in the 80s movie all right and I will
say this I have a huge this little
narrow it down oh no no don't
that don't do that okay okay okay I got
I got my pick right away let's go around
the room fritzy I'm gonna say Bo Derek
and him okay okay Paulie okay I was
gonna go Hoosiers but instead of going
obvious I'm gonna go do the right thing
okay okay that's a good that's a good
call c-calm very ironic okay but he
hates Spike Lee so he would never like
that movie okay I didn't like I didn't
see well I immediately went to Michael
Jackson with Reggie what movie would be
in the Wiz was gonna be McLovin
I'm gonna go Crocodile Dundee you call
that a knife this is a knife my friend
okay I'm gonna go Breakfast Club the
reason why they call you the boss it's
because you know things that's not the
movie but the right director I believe
John Hughes did The Breakfast Club right
yeah I am a huge John Hughes and all
those pretty knees like pretty pink no
it wasn't pretty in pink there was a
movie he directed called some kind of
wonderful yeah yeah Eric Stoltz Eric
Stoltz right wrong side of the tracks
and then Watts who had the short hair
and they you know try to get the rich
girl from the side I know it's stupid
but that was my favorite movie Troy no
it was it Lea Thompson in that Lea
Thompson correct yes she was she was
like the so-called rich girl she never
they went to the house party and they
were gonna beat him up and then the the
games that they were all in detention
together showed up at the right time
yeah all I care about is me my drums and
you and so are you reg safe travels to
fence Berg and I'll talk to you next
week you're the best and Karate Kid I'm
only playing I will still watch you so
Redemption I'm still gonna watch thanks
reg reg will be part of March Madness as
he's going to Pittsburgh yes bowling
Reggie just apologized to a movie yeah
that's okay for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]